шеннон на поні джованну синівської поні
етапу нове нас правді за 1 вид буваєте
на випадок новожилова апогею в
суперечу верховній раді мису
зустрічалася злякати маску лайфхакі тут
за розписати не зацінивши столом і наприклад
я спробую дискусії і звуть шістьма
на ерика та менших колег брата якова
жку сьогодні бочкам у і до них не народилася
вона звучати на дитину прийти і від риму
ти всю інформацію я до них по три дні я
якось допоможе сидить і не вас ти
нормальний спосіб жити а як дасть
чоловіки вид з мети зуба tasty і дитині
я страчуємо і страшні стрес батьки nebula
такої йому жвавості в польську джергу через
повне
інституцій на не по разу мене в Україні
тому що вигляд того моменту я конора g
c дитину починає включати з і різанини
відомства
починаючи перед їхнім протоколом лікарів я
типові не ви його ти і вікна і раніше
проблему чому батьки ви не відразу мід
і яку соціально допомогу місяця може
вранці від і далі батька німає навчилися
як працювати сіють і ти ну і тут
включається індивідуальні вас не
програми ми за 1 відс у нього над
розширенням рудої інклюзивні про світи
україні і що ми вашому
чим раніше дитину почала на чат і з
інклюзивним їжі шанси за краще ти і
шкіль але свиту інклюзивним як що ж ти
ти на ньому оладки мої інклюзивні виразки
і ж проблема яким чином
і дали включати мовчання вінкль у земних
класах звучу yn їх школах тому я обожнюю
що з правді і вторинний факт, що ми
підписуємось і меморандум та яху йому
юнісеф йдучи до нього всім міжнародним
партнерам я кидатися воду покращилася і
ми Петро йому емоцій інституційний
площадки кей повинен проростати зброєю
центрі України д .
як що морити назвати чайну дотяну
можете зайти в інтернет і відразу мід і
куди і ведмедем щось дадуть повний пакет
інформації та пославши для них не йдіть на
ось цей debut з правди результат там у
c початок роботи і я ширю рада що ми
сьогодні поставимо птахом pips та комою
сон кожного міністра та шкірного
представляє який тут підписується травні
далі
коштують та план заходимо що ми досягли
великої важливі вимиті de couleur